[Applause]
Kylie Jenner spared no expense for her
man Travis Scott's 28th birthday bash
[Music]
the astral world rapper was thrown in
papac party Kylie and her sisters Kim
Khloe and Kendall shared a slew of
videos on Instagram from the evening
showing off the intricate details of
this next level event birthday the party
venue appeared to be a fun house but
once inside it was designed to look like
a gas station as for the theme of the
party it was Travis Scott Travis Scott
paper towels Cactus Jack Hennessy
slushies Scots Niki Air Jordan fours
hanging from the trees and so much more
and no this was not the only party Kylie
helps throw for Travis last week the
couple dressed up for an Avengers and
game screening party Kylie as Captain
Marvel and Travis as Iron Man
keilly once again went all out with an
Avengers theme take the red happy
birthday husband no they're not married
according to Kim that's just what they
call each other they call each other
husband and wife are they married
engaged what is the situation
you know I'm literally need to ask her
that is gonna be my next question on our
group chat we were chatting on the way
over here and I think we just saw think
like that's like you know what they call
each other on Tuesday Travis actual
birthday Kylie posted a heartfelt
message that read watching you evolve
into the partner friend son and father
you are today has been so fulfilling my
real-life besties and hubby all wrapped
into one I love you and I'm so so proud
of you happy happy birthday let's
surround and have another baby
[Music]